Nicole Sweeney: Deadly yogurt geiser.
Stefan Chin: Set your phasers to moist.
Sarah Gullickson: Incarcerated toothbrushes.
Timothy Thomas: Smile like a donut.
Caitlin Hofmeister: Microsoft fingernail simulator.
Megan Toenyes: I'm proud of my sand.
Travis Morss: Butter flavored tree gas.
Nicole Sweeney: Long bee squeeze fight.
(Laugh)
Hailey Faust: Molten dog hair.
Lou Winkler: We swam the way giraffes eat
wallpaper.
Michael Aranda: I wanted to sample some spicy
guitar, but I couldn't fit the napkin 'round
it.
Sarah Meismer: Tentacled popcorn.
Hank: There are a lot of different ways to
not make any sense at all, but of all of them,
the fact that some people don't have access
to simple healthcare despite the fact that
we live at the peak moment of wealth in human
history makes the least sense of all.
Partners in Health is dedicated to ending
that weird, lopsided world.
They empower and equip local health workers
and have been working with the people on the
front lines of the fight against ebola before
any of us in the US even knew that there was
an outbreak.
Ebola is a world health problem.
Antibiotic resistance is a world health problem.
Pneumonia is a world health problem.
No community is exempt from these challenges,
and Partners in Health is doing genuinely
heroic work around the world to save lives,
not just now, but a hundred years from now.
Partners in Health is a huge part of the ongoing
success story of increased access to healthcare
and decreased suffering throughout the world,
and through our support, we will also be a
part of that success story.
For the first half of the Project for Awesome,
we'll be splitting the money raised between
Partners in Health and an equally amazing
organization, Save the Children.
We'll also have matching funds for the first
500,000 dollars donated, meaning that if we
reach 500,00 dollars by noon on Saturday,
a total of a million dollars will be given
to partners in health and Save the Children.
During the second half, the money raised will
be distributed via your votes.
To watch videos promoting charities and vote
on the ones that capture your interest and
attention, head to projectforawesome.com.
Together, through the Project for awesome,
we're gonna help the world make a little bit
more sense.
Good morning John!
This was my Project for Awesome video, I'm
looking forward to seeing everybody else's.
So in addition to making videos, watching
videos, voting on charities at projectforawesome.com
we also have the fundraising element.
That takes place over an indiegogo, and it's
just a way to donate to charity, but, in addition
to donating to charity and making the world
a less nonsensical place, you'll also get
stuff!
Stuff that you can't get any other way!
Things like the reproduction of the prop version
of An Imperial Affliction, with seven pages
repeated over and over again, written by John
Green, the author of The Fault in Our Stars
and also my brother and also the guy who runs
this video blog with me.
It's an exact replica of the one that Shailene
Woodley reads in the movie.
We also have the special edition of The Fault
in Our Stars, only available through the Project
for Awesome -- it's green.
Let's see what else.
We've got a calendar, every year we've got
a calendar, but this year the calendar is
baby pictures of YouTubers, including...
this guy.
So.
It's cute.
We got a penny squashing machine, we're squashing
pennies and stamping Project for Awesome and
nerdfighteria logos on 'em.
Death to pennies.
We've also got a couple hundred of these,
hanklerfish arts, yeah, been doing that while
watching Gilmore Girls.
Every one of these is a beautiful moment between
a loving mother and her wonderful daughter.
Katherine and I are doing a full movie commentary
of the Princess Bride, because we love that
movie.
We've got compilations of nerdfighter music
and amazing nerdfighter art that's just...
better than ever; just keeps getting more
awesome every year.
And we'll be adding a ton of Project for Awesome
perks during the 48-hour livestream; can't
spoil all of the surprises now.
And during that livestream, if previous years
are any indication, we will get a little bit
silly and amazing things will happen and we
will be joined by lots of your favorite YouTubers
or at least my favorite YouTubers, and it's
gonna be great.
The livestream will be running from Friday,
that's today, at noon, all the way to Sunday,
at noon.
That's Eastern Time noon, not any other noons.
And now it's time to take it back down again
for the outtro.
Thanks for everybody who helped out here at
the office and thanks to all of you for participating
in the Project for Awesome, whether you're
giving or making videos or hanging out on
the livestream or all of those things.
Our goal here this weekend is just to help
the world make a little bit more sense.
John, I'll see you in the livestream.